so if someone has actually never seen
anything that either of you have done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
oh oh
wow
hmm
well i think the first fantastic beast
is a good start i think so too yeah it's
a nice performance
and
it's very it's such a sweet film and
then you can you can really understand
this film much better if you
saw that one first i feel like
yeah it's a nice
but there are some other
selections that
i would send people to that aren't quite
family friendly
that are
for me
that are yeah me too more yeah but yeah
google me
right
uh i will i will pass that on um these
movies these are huge productions making
a movie of this size and scale what do
you think actually might surprise fans
of this franchise to learn about the
actual making of the movie i feel like
as big as they are
size wise it doesn't feel
that big when you're making it it's
still weird yeah david yates makes it
feel very very intimate almost like a
you know like a much smaller budget film
you know it's like
he also because of the way his his tone
and his manner is so calming
and so you don't feel like there's all
the stress of all the you know the big
circus that we're putting on um which is
which is cool yeah and we've also been
in it together since the beginning
before we were allowed to talk about
these films before anybody knew anything
about them you know we were we were
doing this unknown thing and we
people weren't familiar with me as an
actress certainly like that and
definitely not to the scale and we were
like we were kind of like
we all had a secret together and and
we've been through a lot of
um
life together and and
toward the world promoting the movie and
so i feel like it just feels
like you're obviously wowed by the
scenes and the costumes and things like
that but it fundamentally it's like a
lot of the same people
so it feels very family-owned yet
oriented
i just have to ask you mentioned touring
the world uh you know promoting the
movies um did you ever feel like you're
living like this like spinal tap you
know lifestyle where you're like hello
cleveland but you're really in denver
when you're like you know traveling
like that you know what i mean
yeah sometimes it becomes a blur and you
gotta like check in
just before hopefully you're not on air
you know hopefully it's not live where
you're just like wait where are we again
it's good to like
what are we doing reorient yourself feel
like right here i am yeah um yeah it
gets to be a lot but
um
you know it's
it's fun it's always fun man
it's like uh
what was what was your
i'm just curious what your what your
favorite part of the film was you saw
the whole thing right
yeah and i saw the whole thing i think
uh
i can't talk about spoilers um i just
think that it it has a very it has a
good conclusion you know what i mean
like it has a it really it brings it all
together and i think that steve cloves
uh addition to the screenplay really it
makes you
just it was just very you know it was it
was good like it pulled you you know i
think his his addition to the script
made it feel
you know
i just
i don't i don't know that i'm doing a
very good job explaining this when you
can't talk about spoilers isn't it i i
can't talk about anything specific
i like the part where things happened
and it was
things no but yeah but i think i think
it's a good connection to like it you
know it has the harry potter magic with
these characters and the hogwarts thing
like it just it was it was good i really
enjoyed it yeah i think yeah
nice
so um what is it actually like uh
practicing with the wand at any point
are you sort of just like you know are
you watching the old harry potter movies
to see what they did what is it like
actually practicing i uh i didn't get
any training they just they're like
here's the here's the wand muggle you
know and i i was like oh okay uh and
so i just treated it how i thought that
he like a soldier would treat it so i
held it like a like i drew it like a gun
um which is
you know that's how that's how i handled
it but you had a whole thing you had all
training and everything we did we did um
on the first film what what
um
it kind of came down to
was
um with how your character would hold
the wand and how they would
uh
how they would
use it rather than
trying to focus on how other people have
done it because
it's
it's it's
more it's less about like correct hand
positioning and more about like the your
character's relationship with their wand
um
and my
relation
queenie rarely uses her one because her
magic is
is
just in her so it's it's not that often
that
that she actually gets to do a little
one thing although there was like a a
nice one moment where she got to do a
little
secret smell
when you're making this
yeah that was strudel i kind of tried to
to to channel like a conductor
um
but also like a ballet dancer because i
felt like she sort of conducted things
but she's very
very not a ballet dancer actually a
valley teacher
you know like
and one two three
uh i know that you wouldn't have taken
anything from set on purpose but what
did you hypothetically borrow with every
intention of bringing back
oh
my warming coat
you should never bring those back that
was disgusting it's covered in
mud
um i by accident i took home the a
rumpant uh the um
puppet
oh
uh no you know what colleen um
colleen atwood
made it like a tradition to
allow me to have my my socks
at the end of oh that's again yeah each
movie so
i have socks from each movie which is
cool did you take home anything
oh uh
your warming coat my coat yeah the coat
that was covered it was very there were
some really mucky scenes
um not not on purpose but just had to i
know
i mean loads of underwear you know it's
not it wasn't really the rest of it is
not uh really anything you can it like
your costume ends up
in movie theaters it ends up at the tour
it ends up in
in you know different
the display so as much as i would love
to have
her coat or you know that you just
yeah it's always socks and underwear
right yeah you just did it i mean it's
not exciting but that's what you know
that's the honest truth
um i'm very curious uh who actually is
the one who can make you break the most
on set who's the one that like can just
you know
make you laugh
was there anyone on set who was
purposely trying to make you laugh
sometimes i've heard actors like that i
break myself a lot you're always trying
to make people laugh maths actually is
really funny
math is really funny jessica's funny
jessica's funny yeah i didn't get enough
time with yes oh man she's funny um
eddie could be really yeah
ezra ezra yeah everybody has their
moments especially when you know it's
been a long day
and everyone's been up since really
early and if you're doing a
scene where
you're a little fatigued but it's funny
to see maz be silly in between yeah he's
really he's really he's really dry
but he's really funny oh everybody has
had a moment i think
um on that note i need to stop i'm just
gonna say congrats and i really hope the
film's a huge hit for you guys